I'm come from the school of like I don't
I don't feel comfortable getting
something unless I worked for it so it
feels like I'm like doing my work so I
feel like I belong there more not only
that but I think you know well they're
an actor or not but like it's almost
like they when you get hired just let's
just hire Michael Rosenbaum or let's
hire jamie-lynn Sigler and you get hired
you're almost like I don't know exactly
what they want me to do right and so
then you're hired and then all of a
sudden you're doing it and if you've had
auditioned and got it then like oh
you're like well whatever I did that's
what they want so I'm just gonna do that
it's kind of weird like I hear you guys
want this I don't exactly know what you
wanted am i doing it right either so
there could be like that yes and then to
also reference like the whole MS
conversation of it all in order for me
to feel comfortable I have to have like
the same conversation with everyone I'm
about to work with which is like here's
my limitations
what are they can't run high heels are
hard walking long distances I'm gonna
start to limp so like you know keeping
the shots shorter mornings are better no
no I have full energy like fortunately
it doesn't affect me cognitively energy
wise not everything's just kind of like
the waist down and it's just more it
gets tired but if I sit and rest and I
always tell if I need anything I've
never ever needed a break I've never
told anyone I needed a break because I'm
not trying to like be a superhero I just
have it and then directors and people
are willing to work around it so I've
been very fortunate you know I I still
feel like a burden and I still feel bad
that I have to have that conversation
and I'm comforted every time and being
like please Jamie everybody has
something like this is no big deal we
can figure this out that's not you know
it sounds you're really strong because I
wish I could have these conversations
about my own things beforehand so like
hey listen I eat their insecurities
about myself and like you know if I
found this
I'm that er you know I'm gonna be nice
to do that hey listen man yeah you never
get fired like what this guy's nervous
he gets anxiety that's good
maybe because all of my energy is
channeled in focusing on my physicality
of everything you ever notice it do you
ever notice things when you're watching
pick it apart all the time like you're
like that walk right there that's
because of the MS and I hate it which is
why I don't watch myself around them can
you go to a close-up or can you cut in
no I've never gotten the balls to do
that I always assume that they're gonna
do what looks best and I trust them but
I mean I catch it and it's a bummer it's
and sometimes it's like you know I can
feel like I'm doing great and like
there's still something there and it's
uh it's like I don't know it's a reality
check it's it's it's it's not the most
fun for me
you know because I also you know when
I'm not working and momming like all my
hours sitting here with you I'm you know
like really heavily focused on fighting
this all the time and